herr lauterbach jetzt könnte man sagen
das ist schlicht der bahn sind
vielleicht fangen wir mal mit der frage
an warum haben sich eigentlich die
verantwortlichen ausgerechnet zu unseren
ungunsten verrechnet es war einfach das
ergebnis also wir haben eigentlich zwei
fehler gleichzeitig gemacht wir haben in
den impfzentren zuviel dokumentiert ich
war ja auch im fahrzeug und also da
wurde also der impf aufwand war jenseits
dessen was für 30 minuten pro patient
weil man so das risiko dass man eben was
in wenigen sekunden und für diese da
hatten wir zum glück unsere leute für
aber es war heftig aber man hat in den
impfzentren vier zu vier dokumentieren
und bei den niedergelassenen ärzten viel
zu wenig da wurde noch nichtmals
festgehalten wie alt die leute sind oder
welches geschlecht gar nicht so wohl nur
fest garten ist wurde geimpft und zwar
wo aber nicht woher der patient kann
aber eigentlich hat man gewusst dass
diese zahlen nicht mehr präzise sein
könnten das wusste man seit langem also
mal seit langem dass die zahlen nicht
präzise sein können weil es also klar
war wenn die niedergelassenen ärzte nur
also angeben so viele impfungen haben
viel gemacht
und ich bekomme die abrechnung monate
später und da kann ich mich darauf
natürlich nicht verlassen sind zum
beispiel auch niedergelassene kollegen
gewesen die haben also sich den
dokumentationsaufwand garten gefahren
haben einfach nur geimpft und fertig
waren gar nicht gemeldet und die
betriebsärzte die hatten gar keine klare
regeln einige mussten das so machen wie
die niedergelassen und andere wiederum
ähnlicher wie also die
impfzentren somit gab es da gar keine
klaren regeln daher wussten wir sagt
also ein paar monaten ich drücke mal
über ich teile mal über den draußen die
zahlen stimmten seit zwei monaten
wussten wir dass die zahlen
sozusagen die offiziell dass die nicht
stimmen wir wussten aber nicht genau wie
viel und diese cosimo studi di hat und
dann vor sechs wochen schon mal aus
nicht in frage und genau da hatten wir
dann überlegt das könnte irgendwo auf
der mitte liegen und dass irgendwas
gesundheitswesen sofort die nächste
frage herr aber warum wurde das nicht
kommuniziert warum hat man nicht gesagt
jetzt nach den impfzentren kommen die
betriebsärzte dazu und es kommen die 1
ein praxen dazu und dann werden wir
nicht mehr so richtig präzise wissen
wieviel geimpft wird aber es wird hier
nicht sein ja nur in den zentren in
genau das ist wichtig also dass es für
einen fehler dass man es nicht gemacht
hat und zwar deshalb weil das also
verschwörungstheorien er hat dann kommt
man auf die idee haben wir es
absichtlich nicht gemacht berichtet
wurde wird das gemacht um den freedom
day den wir uns verdient haben auf 2 das
war ich nicht der fall das war nicht der
hintergrund aber solche also
verschwörungstheorien werden dann
natürlich genährt daher hatte man das
viel früher bereinigen müssen und dann
sind wir auf der geografisch rechten
seite dieses tisch ist und freuen uns
dass heute klaus stöhr bei uns ist
epidemiologe biologe 15 jahre für die
whu gearbeitet hersteller sie haben das
natürlich auch verfolgt ist das eine
weitere entscheidung die uns
wird die uns mehr verwirrt als dass sie
präzision ermöglicht wir wissen dass wir
keine besonders präzisen daten haben
werden harte entscheidungen auf einem
nach wie vor sehr wackeligen boden
getroffen erstmals in deutschland
tatsächlich die daten höchster existiert
ich bin jetzt fast 30 haben jedoch in
deutschland haben ein auto gekauft ich
kann an jeder zu jeder zeit an ihrer
tankstelle ablesen wie hoch der
spritpreis ist aber ich kann nicht
herausfinden wie viele leute tatsächlich
geimpft werden in denen morgen schweden
auch in norwegen gibt es im kataster
anhalt mit vielen jahren wirbt auch die
stiko und andere kollegen würden wir
haben dafür seien im kataster angelegt
wird wenn wir das gehabt hätten dann
wäre sicherlich auch diese frage
überhaupt nicht gewesen und man hätte
sogar die leute noch ganz spezifisch
anschreiben können man hätte gewusst du
hast eine vorerkrankung die betreuer du
hast ein übergewicht du hast du eine
lungenerkrankung wir wollen dich zuerst
im fahrzeug das wäre dann alles draußen
vor gewesen aber die realität ist die
wie sie ist ich glaube nicht dass diese
fünf prozent unterschied jetzt so einen
dramatischen sind drei männer
durchschnittlich sind drei millionen
menschen aber muss ja ne ist eine
entscheidung fällen und die entscheidung
meines erachtens wird in einem
größenbereich gefällt wo man sagt der
größte teil über 80 prozent sind jetzt
geimpft und geschützt und dann muss man
schauen wie wir sind dann noch will ich
im fällig oder nicht 66 prozent der
ungeimpften sind im verweigerer
0,9 prozent noch kämpft bereit also wie
viel fehlt denn jetzt eigentlich und wo
finden wir die ja die gibt ja gute
studien die das schon sich angeschaut
haben die fünf prozent machen keinen
großen unterschied jetzt zum schluss
jetzt muss man sich langsam durch regen
zu einer entscheidung aber welcher im
quoten man tatsächlich den frieden aber
es ist interessant sie merken sich
einmal noch die frage müsste nicht
eigentlich in diese zahl auch müssten da
nicht die genehmigungen auch rein
gerechnet werden und landen wir nicht
dann noch höher und was würde das
wiederum für den status deutschlands
bedeute geben sie heben sich das auf und
wir stellen jan josef liefers vor ohne
ihn zu lange vorstellen zu müssen jan
josef gleich zu diesem ersten punkt wie
gefährlich ist es wenn man mit einer
solchen kommunikation eben auch
vermutungen nähert lieder heißen das ist
irgendwie bewusst schwarz gemalt worden
man wollte den druck hochhalten wann hat
extra gewartet dass es nach der wahl ist
haben sie sich das auch gefragt verwirrt
sie dies auch
also ich glaube was das thema
kommunikation angeht und das hätte ich
mir von anfang an eigentlich
besser wünschen können besser vorstellen
können ich glaube das thema
verschwörungen
ich glaube dass zum beispiel die die
angst die eben über viele monate so
unglaublich gesät wurde
ich bin ich wirklich schwer zu
beeindrucken durch so was hättest bei
mir ging das an mir ging das nicht
spurlos vorbei diese angst ist nichts
gutes angst lähmt uns angst macht uns
unkreativ angst macht uns auch anfällig
für aberglauben und für
verschwörungstheorien wir versuchen uns
dann irgendwie die welt zu erklären die
kontrolle zurück zu kriegen und so
kommen dann diese ganzen sachen ist kein
guter nährboden das finde ich generell
aber diese nachricht die jetzt nun kam
die kann ich gar nicht anders sehen als
glücklich ich finde das eine tolle
nachricht weil
ich glaube es war eine woche ich hoffe
dass mir angeschaut sandra maischberger
da warten sie und da ging es ja darum
also dänemark katja diesen freedom day
gefeiert zu einer zeit wo 75 prozent der
erwachsenen dort doppelt gefahren und
ich glaube sie haben sie haben dann so
gerechnet schnell im kopf ausgerechnet
und kam auf 85 und jetzt haben wir doch
schon 85 die wenigstens die erste
impfung auch raimund wenn die in zwei
drei wochen die zweite auch kriegen das
war doch schon da und das ist eigentlich
eine tolle nachricht und ich finde muss
ich sagen diese das was man eben oft so
gesagt hat die deutschen sind impfmuffel
und irgendwie das reicht nicht und das
ist reicht nie und das reicht nicht ich
finde auch die vorwürfe und das sei
unsolidarisch und im film ist nicht nur
eine persönliche ich finde das nicht
richtig ich sehe dass 85 prozent der
deutschen erwachsenen menschen sich ein
impfstoff verabreichen lassen von dem
sie gar nicht so genau wissen und von
dem er dass davon auch nicht vergessen
im internet ihre stories kursieren
darüber über das könnt ihr diskutiert
aber ich meine trotz sachen gesagt
was wir tun es auch für unsere
mitmenschen und wir tun ist für den
freedom day und nun steht er vor der tür
ich find das toll
nicht wurde bei vor der tür und trotzdem
frage ich noch mal ist es nicht
eigentlich eine information über die wir
uns freuen sollten weil viel viel mehr
menschen dieses landes wahnsinnig
vernünftig sich verhalten haben und sich
impfen ließen und sogar doppelt impfen
ließen natürlich das stimmt aber so groß
ist der unterschied dann auch wiederum
nicht stimmig einstürze also dass wir
sind noch immer nicht da wo es möglich
wäre jetzt zu sagen okay jetzt also
nehmen wir die masken runter wir
kontrollieren nicht mehr in den
geschäften das gibt gilt kein 3g mehr
was ich noch nicht freut sich also ist
man wenn es so irrelevant ist christian
drosten sagt das ist klamauk und auf
diese drei millionen leute games nicht
an da sagen sie jetzt auch weiter das
ist nicht richtig nach einer unterschied
das macht einen unter machten schüler
ins rechte licht klamauk ist und wenn es
nicht irrelevant ist
war er also jens spahn sagt ja auch das
bedeutet einen leichteren herbst und
winter für uns alle war offensichtlich
erfolgreich
es ist nicht automatisch so hat man muss
sich anschauen wo wir die defizite haben
wo wir sie nicht haben wir haben also im
vergleich zu dänemark was ja hier oft an
gesprochen wird und sie haben es eben
auch erwähnt wir haben ein problem was
wir schlecht also erklären können
weshalb das so ist diejenigen die über
65 sind sind in deutschland nur zu 85
prozent geben das sind aber diejenigen
die das mit großem abstand größte risiko
das ist in dänemark so zu bemessen über
das auf der grundlage der neuen zahlen
ist das so und also in dänemark sind wir
dabei 96 prozent ist kann man sagen 96
prozent 85 das klingt sehr ähnlich das
muss ich aber von oben rechnen das heißt
also ich habe in dänemark vielleicht
noch vier prozent von den älteren die um
games sind ich habe bei uns an monat
wegen wenn es mal und wegen 84 jahren
hätte ich also 16 prozent die umgeben
sind dann habe ich viermal so viele
ungeimpfte bei den über 65 jährigen in
deutschland wie in dänemark das sind
aber genau die fälle die wir in die
kirche kommen also eine sterblichkeit
von über 10.000 sind sie mit herrn stöhr
einer meinung ist noch mal die frage die
von jan-josef nämlich frau teichert wie
empfinden sie das also wäre es jetzt
nicht eigentlich an der zeit zu sagen
wir haben uns da teilweise geirrt es
sind viel mehr
anstatt sich jetzt irgendwie darüber zu
beklagen und irgendwie wieder zu sagen
das ist alles irrelevant spielt keine
rolle also selbst der
gesundheitsminister findet wir stehen
besser da als gedacht wir sind
erfolgreicher als gedacht also ich muss
mal zu tun ich finde die diskussion sehr
schwierig dass wir merken dass hier
schon mit den zahlen da wird hin und her
argumentieren zwischen den erwachsenen
und der gesamte vorjahr und das aber ich
möchte jetzt eigentlich mal ganz anderen
aspekt auf den tisch legen ich bin
ärztin für mich ist es wichtig zu
verhindern dass jemand erkrankt oder
jemand der erkrankt ist in den heilig
das ist mein beruf und in dem sinne ist
jeder der krank wird der irgendwie
behandelt werden muss für mich eine
person zu viel und dann finde ich die
diskussion mit dem impfquoten und mit
dem hin und her und so finde ich sehr
sehr schwierig ich würde dafür plädieren
doch dann aber geschützt ja dann sind
sie geschützt das ist ja auch super und
so besser je mehr desto besser aber es
kann nicht darum gehen dass wir uns hier
an zahlen lang handeln und anlagenbau
prima das ist aber die marke wenn wir
die haben oder wir sind darunter gar
kein problem jetzt machen wir freedom
day das finde ich so verrückt von der
diskussion her das kann ich gar nicht so
lang und soll man sich denn sonst für
mich ist die diskussion über ein freedom
day stellt sich für mich nicht weil ich
eigentlich möchte dass die leute nicht
erkranken wir haben ein neues virus und
deshalb was die menschen kommen diese
freiheit nie wieder 2 darum wird es
überhaupt nicht aber ich finde die
argumentationslinie ist so sehr
schwierig nachzuvollziehen aus
medizinischer sicht ok aber mit da sind
ja menschen die haben sich sehr
vernünftig verhalten sie haben sich in
größerer zahl sehr vernünftig verhalten
als wir ursprünglich dachten und es gibt
jetzt verschiedenste reaktionen darauf
also zum einen hätte man sich gewünscht
von anfang an informiert worden zu sein
als bürger dass das so ist
offensichtlich sind wir nicht dazu in
der lage weil wir eine daten höchste
sind und die dinge irgendwie immer noch
mehr schätzen aber wir versetzen uns
eben leider häufig zu unseren ungunsten
und das ist jetzt die frage die man
vermeidet dass solche dinge zukünftig
geschehen denn sie demotivieren
natürlich auch jedes liegt aber an weil
die diskussion geführt wird wie sie
geführt es ist prima natürlich jeder der
geimpft ist und auch die quoten sind
ganz toll finde es super wäre hätte das
letztes jahr gedacht dass wir dieses
jahr jetzt schon seit sind dass wir den
impfstoff haben dass so viele geimpft
sind es denn die sind ja wirklich
geschützt die werden schon die sind
geschützt und drechseln buße ja genau
und trotzdem trotzdem haben wir keine
grenzen das ist ja willkürlich was wir
diskutieren natürlich gibt es berechnung
dass man sagt okay 85 müssen wir
erreichen aber das ist ja nicht so dass
es eine grenze ist wenn wir die erreicht
haben zeigt dann gehen wir darüber und
darunter kommen war weg und haben ein
problem wir leben ja auch ein bisschen
in der welt der umwelt also die man kann
ja jetzt nicht so tun als hätten wir
keine nachbarn und und dieses gefühl
dass das man hier so hängen im schacht
hat gerade natürlich nur noch ein
bisschen bestärkt durch die zeit
zwischen zwei regierungen also zwischen
den jahren zwischen den regierungen aber
wir können nicht so tun als also wir
können nicht einfach zugucken das im um
uns herum sozusagen immer mehr freiheit
dürfen während wir die einzigen sind die
sagen nein das können sie auf gar keinen
fall einer zahl festmachen also
irgendeine art von aussicht und exit
strategie brauchen wir jetzt ich habe es
ja schon im wahlkampf habe ich mich
schon gewundert dass das für keine der
parteien im thema ist also so als gäbe
es hört dass das gar nicht gegeben war
der wahlkampf jetzt brauchen wir einmal
irgendeine art von entschuldigung aber
man hängt immer so ne wurst davor die
nase
wenn jeder ein impf angebot hatte dann
müssen wir mit den maßnahmen sollen die
sanitär gleich so
und natürlich ist genau das die frage an
welcher stelle wir von der politik von
der regierung dieses landes
eben einen neuen fahrplan gekommen für
das was jetzt eigentlich erreicht ist in
dem land und wo wir unsere zielmarke
setzen zu sorgen ab da dürften
erleichterungen stattfinden ich drehe
jetzt trotzdem noch mal eine kleine
runde mit einer aktion die der jan josef
liefers mitgemacht hat das erinnern sie
noch er war teil der initiative alles
dicht machen und das hatte folgen und
das gucken uns schon normal
jan josef liefers einer der beliebtesten
tatort darsteller der deutschen ist mit
dabei im april schauspieler kritisieren
unter dem hashtag alles dichtmachen in
satire videos die korona maßnahmen von
alarmismus spricht liefers der ganz ganz
oben bleiben solle wir sollten einfach
nur allem zustimmen und tun was man uns
sagt nur so kommen wir gut durch die
pandemie die empörung groß die
schlagzeilen verheerend die medizin
bloggerinnen und notärztin carola holz
laut per video die schauspieler ein
dienst auf der intensivstation zu
schieben liefers tut genau das und macht
seine erfahrungen öffentlich er erzählt
von schwerkranken und sterbenden jungen
menschen alle und hilft dennoch ist er
gegen mehr druck auf sie kritisiert
stattdessen die politik für ihre
sprachlosigkeit
wir hängen hier im schacht ohne richtige
ansage ohne richtige perspektive ok
derzeit auch ohne richtige regierung da
will wohl von den altvorderen keiner
mehr was entscheiden oder
das große schweigen gerade hat das noch
mal gesagt und gefragt war in ihren
augen jan josef liefers tatsächlich die
bundestag wichtige bundestagswahl
plötzlich wichtiger als die pandemie
so gut na ja also solltest ja auch
wichtig also was soll man schon mal
wichtig nehmen und das ist ein wahlkampf
hingegen ging ja auch um einiges und und
ich spüre schon auf so einen riss der
oder vielleicht sogar mehrere risiken
die die hier in unserem land
aufgebrochen sind in dieser zeit darf
man nicht unterschätzen es war kein
schöner stress für alle für die
befürworter der regierungsmaßnahmen
genauso viel wie für die kritiker am
ende sind alle hier geht keiner ohne
dellen aus und deswegen hat sie mich
gewundert dass das im wahlkampf so gar
keine rolle spielte war gar kein thema
also es ginge jetzt nach vorne so als
wäre das schon längst abgehakt ist die
forschungsgruppe wahlen herr stöhr hat
gesagt dass die pandemie politik gar
nicht ein großes thema war bei den
bundestagswahlen hatte sie auch verwirrt
dass wir nicht mehr die wöchentlichen
pressekonferenzen hatten dass wir auch
frau merkel nicht mehr dazu gehört haben
dass wir auch andere kollegen
ministerpräsidenten irgendwie nicht mehr
gehört haben meine kollegen sowie lehrer
verliebt ich habe ein brief geschrieben
euro an den bundestag an alle fraktionen
der parteien gefragt wann endlich mal
tatsächlich die position klar werden in
dem wahlprogramm was danach passieren
sollte was danach sein ziel die
zukünftige regierung machen wir denn der
pandemie eine partei hat sich geäußert
war die fdp die hat tatsächlich
beantwortet alle anderen dort war
schweigen im walde gewesen und so sieht
das leben war das ja jetzt auch was mich
eigentlich mehr verwirrt hat ich komme
ja nun von außen ich habe deutschland
sagen ja nicht gesehen ist wie man von
der bundesregierung proaktiv die
strukturierte
risikobewertung und risikokommunikation
abgefordert hat normalerweise ist es ja
so wenn man nichts fragt ein system
aufbaut dann bekommt man auch keine
multidisziplinäre
forschungsagenda dann gibt es auch keine
kein pandemie komitee wie was eigentlich
international kennen und dann gibt es
immer wieder einzelne meinung und ich
glaube man hat mir ein großes vakuum
gelassen nicht nur in der kommunikation
sondern auch in krisen management und
dieses vakuum sehen wir ja jetzt
umfragen zeigen 55 prozent der menschen
glauben immer noch dass sie sich niemals
infizieren 40 prozent der menschen
glauben dass die erkrankung bei kindern
schwer ist so longo wird haben sehr
viele negativ gehört über das letzte
jahr was ich auch nicht mehr angepasst
hat also ich glaube dass man diese
ganzen mythen es wird herdenimmunität
geben impfung heißt niemand scheidet aus
und bleibt gesund alle diese dinge hat
man nicht proaktiv in der
krisenkommunikation angesprochen
angedacht und jetzt glaubt ein
multidisziplinäres team was auch die
bundesregierung ließ maier das ist
interessant wenn dieselben auch beraten
hat er diesen expertenrat hätte es geben
sollen in dem eben nicht nur einzelne
virologen gehört sehe mal das krisen
management und großen firmen hat man
immer ein multidisziplinäres team man
fragt natürlich nicht nur den ein wenn
ich den virologen fr gesagt mein gott
wir haben vier neue aminosäuren ganz
schlimm neue pandemie es gibt ein turbo
virus nicht gut dann fahre ich den
intensivmediziner natürlich laufen
intensivstationen voll da sagte alles zu
machen aber dass weder der
wirtschaftswissenschaftler noch dabei
noch der pädiater noch der pneumologe
der soziologe oder krisen kommunikator
die müsste man eigentlich alle zusammen
nehmen wegsperren und sagen wir brauchen
jetzt drei
alternativen zur bekämpfung und die
sollen auch alle durchführbaren
vielleicht eine auf die gesundheit
ausgerichtet ein auf die wirtschaft auf
die freiheitlich-demokratische richtung
und dann möchte ich als politiker diese
drei optionen vorgestellt bekommen mit
den vor und nachteilen dann möchte ich
natürlich entscheiden und eine kluge
entscheidung fällen wollen da sind wir
jetzt schon bei den lehrern ich hatte
vorher noch eine konkretere frage
stellen wollen nämlich die danach was
sie sagen herr stöhr was wäre jetzt
eigentlich für sie die zahl nochmal 75
dänemark oder 67 bei den holländern
gesamtbevölkerung achtung
wo wir sagen wir lassen locker und
objektive politische entscheidung wir
haben es ja gesehen dass frankreich die
schweiz und andere länder mit
intelligenten von 450 500 einigermaßen
gut durch den winter gekommen die haben
ja darüber dass uns dass 60 prozent der
chor wird patienten auf den
intensivstationen
corvette patienten waren die haben doch
so geregelt aber haben die schulen und
kindergärten die ganze zeit offen in
deutschland nennt man einen anderen weg
gefahren also auch hier ist es eine
subjektive entscheidung von der
politik eine politische
entscheide ich ob ich das noch sagen
sich ansonsten aus meiner perspektive
wenn ich nur epidemiologisch betrachtet
würde ich sagen soll wenn die infektion
der erkrankung in der auswirkung
vergleichbar ist mit anderen
infektionserkrankungen die auch anders
behandelt werden dann möchte ich dir
auch ähnlich behandelt wir wissen ja was
bei der influenza passiert wir wissen
was bei den adenoviren renovieren
renovieren meta probieren anderen
während passiert wird geimpft oder nicht
geimpft wir wissen dass die kinder sich
im übrigen alter infizieren und wenn
dieser status in dieser status erreicht
ist bei der korona virusinfektion also
genau so viele erkrankte sehen genauso
viel die auf die intensivstation
gekommen genauso viele die auch mal nur
zu hause bleiben dann haben wir die
integrieren und sie eine zahl nennen
oder sie könnten nicht eine zahl nennen
im klub noch mal bei 85 prozent wie wir
noch mal wir haben jetzt zehn prozent
der noch nicht geimpften sind im
verweigern die werden sich nicht mehr
impfen lassen und dann haben wir noch
fünf prozent der noch impfen können
jetzt und davon sind 15 bereit wie weit
wollen wir das jetzt noch treiben wir
sind bei herrn lauterbach hertha war
wieder auch diese beiden fragen wo war
die politik in der zeit des wahlkampfes
das sage ich ganz schnell dann muss ich
aber auch einige designer
kurzzuschließen politik ich finde es gut
dass also die korona politik keine
wahlkampf politik gewesen ist sondern
dass wir das gemacht haben was wir
vorher gemacht haben man hätte doch die
bevölkerung weiter informieren das ist
eine andere sache aber ist nur ein
liefers hat ja eben gesagt hat so war es
im wahlkampf und sie hatten gesagt was
ist denn die wahlkampf was ist sozusagen
die was will die lincoln bezug auf uns
warten
dass wir in deutschland diesen sonderweg
gegangen sind und haben keine
parteipolitik gemacht in der korona
politik das war richtig dass es sehr gut
bekommen und das haben wir auch im
wahlkampf durchschlagen das war nicht
wichtig dass man dann gleichzeitig mehr
von der regierung hätte sehen müssen ist
unbenommen das ist richtig ich möchte
keine leute in der regierung kritisieren
spezifisch aber da hatte man einfach
mehr halt mehr orientierung geben wir
jetzt haben ist ja eben nicht eine
geordnete situation sondern jetzt macht
das saarland was ist möchte und öffnet
sie nur hätte man an der weitere also
bund länder konferenz gehabt hätte man
mehr vom bundesgesundheitsministerium
gehört aber alle tatsächlich gehabt
jetzt haben wir nicht gab es ist
trotzdem etwas anderes das muss ein gut
unterscheiden als einmal parteipolitik
um corona das habe nicht gab
januar geben müssen das hat uns sehr gut
geholfen dass wir nicht sozusagen auf
eine billige art und weise wer bietet
mehr wer ist hier das schnell zu
befrieden also ich mache wahlkampf ich
bin sozusagen ich biete euch den
schnellsten aber bis jetzt hier auch
alles ganz schön 85 prozent gesagt es
ist es eine politische entscheidung
nicht nur hier ist eine politische
entscheidung war so ruhig die kwl
herdenimmunität kann ist also aus
epidemiologischen gründen mit diesem
virus nicht geben somit muss ich im
prinzip die entscheidung weil sie gar
nicht geben kann denn sie es sagt ja
weile in dem es dafür müssten die
impfstoffe noch stärker sein also der
wert ist also der reproduktions wert ist
so hoch dass ich also eine also wenn ich
dann zu einer herdenimmunität kommen
wollte rechnerisch eine impfung haben
muss den noch stärker wirkt als die sage
ja mal 8 85 bis 90 prozent ich in der
praxis bekomme somit also da die
herdenimmunität die garage ist kann ich
mir jetzt politik überlegen wie viele
leute lasse ich noch sterben bevor ich
quasi öffnen und was also kostet mich
das und das ist tatsächlich also eine
entscheidung die wir auch in der
vergangenheit also immer getroffen haben
implizit und deutschland hat das mache
sich das muss gesagt sein ist ganz
besonders wichtig wir haben das gut
gemacht wir haben eine sterblichkeit in
deutschland die fast besser die besser
ist als die sterblichkeit fast alle
anderen länder die eine alte struktur
haben wie wir es gibt ganz wenige länder
ich glaube 3 die eine geringere
sterblichkeit haben bei unserer
altersstruktur und ich könnte 30 länder
nenne ich habe noch mal geguckt die
holländer liegen hinter uns die
niederlande liegt hinter uns ja weniger
also prozentual auf 100000
man muss es auf die alte spiel schweden
haben eine schlechtere sterben haben
eine schlechtere ich werde zwar noch aus
rechnet die ersten jahr die zwei monate
ich kann nix raus rechnen wenn leute
gestorben sind also die wenn es sind 34
länder die noch besser sind als wir ist
in der w30 die schlechter sind als wir
und daher also halten ich mag es gar
nicht wenn das was also wir gemacht
haben schlecht geräte und jetzt auch der
eine punkt wie die beratungsgremien da
würde immer gesagt da waren nur
virologen drin und das ist nicht richtig
dass ich sage dass er nur wie rücken
oder ist natürlich noch andere dabei
hatte nach minuten zeit gehabt
ministerpräsident kommt genau und ihre
meinung zu sagen also macht man keine
krisen der aber die daten zum beispiel
angela merkel hat zum beispiel einen
stab von wissenschaftlern der auch
diverse zusammengesetzt waren der
regelmäßig also beraten hat jens spahn
hat einen relativ großen berater stark
gehabt ich glaube kann man sagen da sind
wir beide auch drin und da sind viele
drin da soziologen die sehr namhaft ist
und so weiter und da sprechen wir haben
dort auf überstunden gesprochen über
stunden das heißt das so darzustellen
als wenn es keine beratung gegeben hätte
ist nicht richtig und schließlich also
wir müssen da stimme ich ihnen zu wir
müssen ein ende irgendwie es wäre jetzt
die nächste frage und wassergarten 85
prozent aus kann der herdenimmunität
gibt glaube ich dass wir also darauf
achten müssen was das wichtigste ist
dass wir bei den über 65-jährigen auf
die kommt an dass wir bei den über
65-jährigen so hinkommen dass wir da
vielleicht noch also idealerweise wäre
95 prozent aber auf jeden fall über 90
prozent kommt und wir müssen uns was
überlegen für unser kind war in dem
moment wo wir öffnen dann haben wir
damit zu rechnen dass wir eine
durchsuchung bei unseren kindern zu
sehen bekommen weil wir reden vielleicht
schon merken wir uns jan josef liefers
ihre zeit auf diese intensivstation
hat die sie gelehrt dass wir schon zur
normalität zurückkehren können
also
um ist erstmal eins zu sagen also das
war ja so eine aufforderung die am
anfang so klang wie du hast überhaupt
keine ahnung ihr quasselt den wolf geht
auch mal hin und mache ich kenne
intensivstationen sehr gut mein vater
lag lange auf einer und ist dann auch
auf einer gestorben ich habe dort sehr
viel zeit zugebracht auf intensivstation
hinzu kommt dass ich ohnehin ein
medizinisch interessierter mensch bin
das heißt ich gehe sowieso überall hin
und frage jedem loch im bauch was ist
das war nicht unbedingt notwendig aber
was es mich vor allem gelehrt hat war
und das war meine lehre sich die frage
gestellt da gar nix gelernt er liefert
der liefert was gelernt er hat was
gelernt was er vorher nicht so klar dass
die pflege das pflegepersonal auf seiner
station
absolut aufwertung verdient und
wertschätzung nicht nur mit applaus das
ist auch in ordnung sondern auch mit
geld das sind leute die arbeiten dort
sehr hart ich habe es ja ein bisschen
mitgeholfen natürlich was so gingen also
ein bisschen um betten und ist den
körperpflege und so und hab war hat das
beobachtet wie die mit denen reden ich
mal dass leute die liegen im künstlichen
koma die höheren wahrscheinlich gar
nichts das weiß man nicht aber sie sagen
wir wissen es nicht deswegen sagen wir
dass wir gehen nicht einfach hin und
rütteln an jemandem andrehen ihn auf die
andere seite und die 1000 schläuche und
was da alles zu beachten das ist ein
unglaublicher einsatz
und dann kommt noch dazu dass ja
aufgrund des infektionsschutz
familienmitglieder dort nicht hin können
das heißt wenn es dann ans ende geht
setzen die sich auch noch hin und halten
die hand und tun etwas was sonst
familienangehörige und verwandte tun und
das steht nicht in ihrem arbeitsvertrag
also da wir alle immer älter werden und
wahrscheinlich alle immer mehr
in zukunft pflege brauchen und wir
können nicht alles von robotern machen
lassen das ist die lehre was ich gelernt
habe aus dieser sache das ist dass es
für menschen dass diese krankheit covi
19 für menschen manche menschen
verheerende zerstörungen anrichtet
das habe ich gesehen dass bei mir aber
auch vorher schon klar und was ich nur
meine ist das ist sozusagen das eine
spektrum und das ist keine wollte die
ich dann mache wenn ich zum beispiel
sage ich glaube nicht an dieser art von
druck und pressing aggressiven pressing
was wir auf und kämpfte ausüben und
diese art war glaube ich nicht das eine
ist das eine ende des spektrums das
anderes das andere natürlich versuche
permanent meinen blick zu erweitern und
zeigen wird sich aber wenn sie sehen wie
die menschen leiden gleich wenn sie
sehen wie die menschen daran leiden und
sterben
das
macht ihnen nicht angst weil sie selber
für sich die entscheidung gefällt haben
sich impfen zu lassen
und das wir vorher entschieden haben und
sagen ich verstehe nicht warum die das
nicht gemacht haben oder geht ihnen das
schon durch den kopf und sie sagen
einfach nur das soll jeder mensch selber
entscheiden ob er ich kann das nicht
bewerten ich bin kein mediziner ich habe
einfach nur gesagt was dort mir gesagt
oder die mediziner dort das personal die
lagerarbeiter tagung gesagt vermutlich
würde keiner von denen hier liegen hätte
er sich impfen lassen das wäre so
schlimm nicht gekommen das habe ich
wieder gegeben und mehr sage ich dazu
nicht ich kann weder eine empfehlung
geben noch kann ich davon abraten ich
kann nur meine geschichte erzählen ich
habe meine katzen medizinischen daten
offengelegt in dieser geschichte und
aber gesagt ich habe das genau verfolgt
ich bitte kämpfte ich habe monate danach
diesen status noch mal kontrollieren
lassen mit den ganzen antikörpern und
sehr neutralisiert und und und und
humorale zelluläre immunität kann ich ja
dass mir merken was auf diesem zettel
steht und ich kann nur sagen ich bin ein
beispiel für eine gut funktionierende
impfung und das heißt aber nicht dass
ich dir jetzt bin er sagt macht das auch
macht das auch machst du das auch macht
das auch am ende muss es jeder selbst
ist und da wir ein staats und dessen
regierung sich dagegen ausgesprochen hat
eine impfpflicht anzuordnen gibt es sie
nicht dass heißt es ist freiwillig wenn
wir das bestimmen als regierung dann
können wir nicht zulassen dass sozusagen
von hinten durch die kalte küche hat
durch die hintertür derartig rabiates
pressing auf leute ausgeübt wird die
dann von dieser freiheit gebrauch machen
und sagen dann möchte ich das lieber
nicht und es gibt ja auch viele die
würden noch eine impfung nehmen wenn es
noch einen anderen impfstoff gebe es
gibt einfach auch viel das darf man
nicht unterschätzen m rna ist eine neue
sache ich bin's faszinieren mich
begeistert das ist auch so eine art aber
es gibt viele leute die die teilen das
nicht sonderlich sagten ist hier das ist
mir zu dir ist sich jetzt sofort in
dieser runde über den im druck und über
den direkten und indirekten druck der da
auf die impflinge ausgeübt wird so würde
es jan josef liefers formuliert haben
und so empfinden es wahrscheinlich auch
manche die sich in der situation
befinden sich noch nicht entschieden zu
haben ich möchte an dieser stelle ganz
kurz und mit dem größten interesse
natürlich in paris schalten zu unserem
kollegen thomas walde mit folgendem
hintergedanken immer nur immer korn der
französische präsident
gibt einen ausserordentlichen druck auf
die franzosen sich impfen zu lassen und
das wäre jetzt genau die frage wie macht
er das und mit welchem erfolg
thomas weiter guten an als sie den
erfolg in anführungszeichen wenn man das
so definieren will kann man hier sehen
im gesundheitsministerium in paris dass
die zahl angegeben der menschen die im
land geimpft sind 51 millionen etwa drei
viertel aller franzosen sind geimpft die
zahl der neuinfektionen ist in den
vergangenen wochen deutlich
zurückgegangen die zahl der menschen die
auf intensivstationen liegen ebenfalls
und da berichtet auch das
gesundheitsministerium etwas ganz
ähnliches wie jan josef liefers
berichtet hat dass dort nämlich neun von
zehn patienten auf intensivstationen in
frankreich ungeimpfte sind und für wen
gilt nun eine impfpflicht und für welche
regeln
sind ausgeschrieben für die ungeimpften
eine impfpflicht gibt es für
beschäftigte im gesundheitswesen und das
wird auch sanktioniert wenn die nicht
geimpft sind das wird relativ streng
kontrolliert darüber hinaus gibt es
einen druck in der öffentlichkeit der zu
sagen kritiker einer impfpflicht doch
gleich komme wenn man am öffentlichen
leben in frankreich teilnehmen möchte
braucht man einen so genannten
gesundheitspass das ist der nachweis
dass man geimpft gewesen oder getestet
ist der wird auch kontrolliert den
braucht man wenn man ins restaurant geht
durchaus auch draußen nur auf die
terrasse oder wenn man zug fahren möchte
überland überregional das wurde in
deutschland ja auch mal kurzzeitig
diskutiert dort nicht angeführt hier
schon dann gibt es darüber hinaus noch
anreize in schulen beispielsweise bei
den kindern den höheren klassen älteren
kinder werden dort ein kind positiv
getestet wird in einer klasse dürfen die
kinder die geimpft sind weiter zur
schule gehen die die nicht geimpft sind
müssen in den heimunterricht haben viele
eltern gesagt das wollen wir nicht wir
lassen die impfen und ab morgen wird der
druck noch einmal erhöht dann sind die
tests in frankreich nämlich
kostenpflichtig wir dann sich testen
lassen will um beispielsweise ins kino
zu gehen oder so der darf dafür dann 44
euro zusätzlich bezahlen 44 euro und in
frankreich gab es auch proteste thomas
neben die unter diesem zusätzlichen
druck jetzt zu oder ab
es gab eine diskussion in frankreich
auch um den begriff der freiheit vor
allem die extreme rechte hier marine le
pen die präsidentschaftskandidatin hat
gesagt die politik der regierung ist ein
anschlag auf die freiheit mit diesem
gesundheitspass die regierung hat
erwiderte das ermöglicht uns doch erst
freiheit nehme ich das mal wieder ins
kino geht oder ähnliches zu beginn gab
es dagegen sehr große umfangreiche
öffentliche proteste da sind an den
samstagen
200.000 mehr menschen auf die straße
gegangen gegen den gesundheitspass gegen
die imk politik der regierung aber diese
zahl hat dann in den vergangenen wochen
doch auch spürbar abgenommen am
vergangenen samstag waren es landesweit
weniger als 50.000 menschen die noch auf
die straße gegangen sind das zeigt also
auch da eine gewisse entwicklung die
parallel läuft im grunde zu den
infektionszahlen und das heißt im grunde
auch dass frankreich nicht nur in dieser
gesellschaftlichen atmosphäre sondern
nun auch wirtschaftlich wieder besser da
steckt
ja insgesamt schon man man spürt dass im
alltagsleben dass vieles wieder möglich
ist die wirtschaft wächst wieder zum
jahresende will frankreich wieder auf
dem niveau von vor der krise sein auch
die arbeitslosigkeit sinkt derzeit
spürbar
man merkt es auch in kleinigkeiten
heute war der erste tag in paris wo
wieder von behörden gewarnt wurde vor zu
viel feinstaub in der luft also man
sieht auch da geht es wenn man so sagen
will wieder aufwerten so thomas walde
ganz herzlichen dank nach paris und
einen guten abend und damit haben wir
hier natürlich den sofortigen impuls
nach genau unserem strategie zu fragen
herr stöhr was sagen sie wäre eine
impfpflicht für deutschland nicht
ehrlicher und aufrichtiger als jetzt so
hintenrum die quarantäne muss selber
bezahlt werden die des lands end euro
die leute mit dem geldbeutel zu
überreden ich bin kein soziologe und
kein psychologe da müssen wir natürlich
habe jetzt einzeln bürger eine meinung
dazu ich glaube die überzeugung wäre
besser und ich glaube wir haben genug
wissen um zu entscheiden zu können wer
sind die gruppen die eigentlich
neue informationen bekommen müssen wir
auf den sind die stationen das sind ja
zum großteil als ungeimpfte und weil die
dort liegen ein sehr großer teil sind
übergewichtige raucher personen mit
migrationshintergrund und personen aus
sozial ökonomischen schwachen region das
sind vielleicht leute die nasen heute
schon aus soziologischer studien das ist
dass das sind die informationen die von
einem intensiv von der intensivstation
ja das ist natürlich keine
deutschlandweit
repräsentative stichprobe das ist das
was die kollegen auf den
intensivstationen berichten ja ja und
auch erheben klar und jetzt fragt man
sich wie erreicht man diese menschen
erreicht mir die damit mit 2g und 3g
das sind ja nicht diejenigen die ins
restaurant gehen die in die diskothek
gehen und die bar die belassen sie ja
vielleicht gar nicht testen kann man
dadurch die impfquote erhöhen oder es
ist ja zuvor
in letzter zeit sind zwölf prozent der
menschen mehr als einmal pro woche
getestet worden also zwölf prozent
lassen sich nur jede woche testen 50
prozent lassen sich gar nicht testen
haben sich in den letzten vier wochen
überhaupt nichts fest das gibt ein gutes
studio cosmo
erfolgt sofort publiziert diese daten
sind frei zugänglich
erreichten die erreicht man jetzt diese
menschen und tatsächlich sind jetzt 66
prozent der über 60 jährigen um auf
ihren punkt zu kommen 66 prozent der
über 60 jährigen sind impfverweigerer
wie erreicht man die wie erreicht man
die vielleicht fragen wir uns das noch
mal und fragen auch frau teichert noch
mal als erstes die aktionen sind
namenlos also man wird mit döner
beschenkt man wird mit geld beschenkt
man kann es vor einer disco machen man
kann es an den bars machen in den
arztpraxen sowieso
was würden sie sagen was muss die
politik noch erfinden was müssen wir
noch erfinden um mehr menschen zu
überzeugen und eben nicht zu überreden
oder dazu indirekt zu zwingen also was
ich glaube was sehr gut ist dass wir
rausgehen dass wir die leute dort
aufsuchen wo sie sind in den mobilen
impft teams in den impfdosen dass wir
auch in die settings reingehen also ich
habe zum beispiel jetzt bei uns erlebt
da hat der karnevalsverein aufgerufen
hat gesagt wenn der karneval feiern
wollten lasst euch impfen und dann stand
das prinzenpaar vorne und hat vorne weg
sozusagen geworben auch beim fußball
kenne das ja im fußballstadion dass die
leute nur rein gelassen werden wenn sie
in impfnachweis haben und dass auch die
fußballer dazu aufrufen ich glaube wir
müssen in die lebenswelten der menschen
gehen und dann müssen wir eben gucken wo
haben wir da defizite oder wo müssen wir
hinten das halte ich für eine sehr gute
geschichte und so ja gerne würde ich
gern noch mal anknüpfen hat das was sie
eben gesagt haben alle was war das fand
ich ausgesprochen wichtig mit dem appell
für die pflege ich glaube das ist das
was wir noch zu wenig diskutieren wir
diskutieren hier über die impfquoten
über die herdenimmunität aber dass das
personal so stark belastet ist in den
auf den intensivstationen und das
natürlich auch ein faktor ist den wir
jetzt berücksichtigen müssen wenn wir
auf den winter gucken
die leute sind ausgelaugt und das
betrifft die pflege und das betrifft
aber auch die gesundheitsämter da sind
menschen die arbeiten seit anderthalb
jahren anderen schlag durch welche
wochenende die kennen keine überstunden
oder machen die am laufenden meter so
und die sind einfach ausgelaugt und
fertig und wir haben nur noch eine
gewisse zeit wir haben jetzt den winter
vor uns ja wir sind in der entwicklung
von medikamenten auch das wird
sicherlich bald kommt es werden weitere
impfstoffe kommen also die die situation
wird immer besser und man muss doch
jetzt nur die zeit überbrücken die noch
vor uns so über welche zeit reden wir
und wir wollen nicht vergessen dass
tatsächlich ein josef hat das
angesprochen ja die frage ist ist das
was mit den menschen geschieht die sich
noch nicht haben impfen lassen
mittlerweile erpressung weil wir ihnen
finanzielle
nachteile bescheren indem wir sagen du
hast deine persönlichen tests zu
bezahlen du hast zu bezahlen wenn du in
quarantäne muss dann gibt es keine
lohnfortzahlung und du hast übrigens
auch restaurants und opernhäuser in die
du gar nicht rein darfst wenn du nicht
getestet bist weil wir das einfach nicht
erlauben so wäre es den fehler zu sagen
wir machen eine impfpflicht einfach weil
wir wissen dass es richtig ist und das
ist die menschheit erlöst und das ist
wirklich eine andere situation in dieses
land bringen also damit einen anderen
status an ich bin da kann kann sein dass
alle das schon wissen irgendwie ich habe
es bis heute nicht genau verstanden
warum ist das geht das dann nicht warum
machen wir keine wo wir doch überzeugt
sind das ist das beste was wir diesen
gehören freilich genau verstanden warum
sie denn nicht gibt warum man das so zu
sagen so
ich würde es ein heimtückischer
sozusagen mit winkelzügen hintenrum dann
muss man solche taktik gleich was du das
sind keine winkelzüge wenn ich zwei geht
ab sofort aber ich will das mach ich das
nicht gehen lassen das wird das wirkt
immer so unseriös wenn wir hier mit
winkelzügen die leute also drängen
würden austricksen würden die ich
kriegen wenn ich durch und du machen
musst wenn jemand also in einer
ende sommer da nicht reingehen kann war
dort zweig ist dann ist das in keiner
weise hinter türkisch oder was auch
immer sondern einfach wir wollen einfach
nicht dass jemand da reingeht und die
anderen gefährdet so einfach ist es und
warum gibt es keine impfpflicht an
endlich gibt es aus politischen und aus
epidemiologischen gründen nicht
epidemiologisch kann ich dann endlich
nur begründen wenn ich sonst also
herdenimmunität nicht darstellen kann
das ist üblicherweise also wie man eine
nebenpflicht begründet mit der endlich
bekomme ich herdenimmunität da zum
beispiel beim master machen oder so
werden es aber sowieso keine möglichkeit
gibt eine herdenimmunität zu erreichen
wie wir das hier haben dann ist das
epidemiologische argument für die eben
schlicht zumindest nicht einfach um es
mal so auszudrücken jetzt kommt das
politische argument natürlich wissen wir
alle dass eine impfpflicht also nicht
durchsetzbar wäre weil die menschen die
in deutschland also sich nicht impfen
lassen woran es gibt ja einen harten
kern das ist ja auch ein kern der
politik mobilisiert wird die afg und
auch andere rechte gruppen machen ja
mobil die sagen lasst euch nicht impfen
die impfstoffe sind gefährlich also
lasst euch eure freiheit nicht nehmen
nun soweit und das heißt wie in anderen
europäischen ländern ist auch bei uns so
dass die rechten kräfte die impfungen
nutzen um sozusagen zusätzliche
anhängerschaft zu besorgen und wir
wollen doch nicht mit der impfpflicht
diesen kräften noch zu arbeiten nur das
gewöhnlich machen daher möchten
überzeugen so und jetzt haben sie jeden
user boniface gesagt dass er nichts
verstanden hat mit seinem besuch auf der
intensivstation es war vielleicht ein
bisschen hart
aber warum fanden sie das ist nicht
durchaus ein argument ist zu sagen man
kann die leute nicht missionieren und
nicht jeder kann gezwungen werden das
zwei gründe zum einen ich hab mir grad
schon beschrieben ich glaube nicht dass
die leute zwingen das ist einfach nicht
so wenn ich also wenn irgendwann aber
wenn ein café oder einer bar oder was
auch immer so 200 leute drei siege sind
margarita unten tests sind zusammen 30
euro die muss ich haben wenn ich mir
leisten können will nicht geimpft zu
sein nein es gibt noch zahlreiche es
gibt doch zauber ich wenn ich raus
möchte er in der diskussion ist doch
falsch aber ich kann auch nicht immer
nur auf die ungeimpften gucken wir haben
der größte teil es geimpft aber und
sozusagen jemandem erhalten sozusagen
wir wissen ja kann ich doch nicht immer
sagen ich bestraft die umkämpfte
sachlich falsch im gegenteil ich belohne
die die geübt so nicht mehr doch man
muss es auch mal aus der perspektive des
ungeimpfter sehen zum beispiel und trägt
jetzt vor ich will in die bar eingehen
können da sind 200 leute ich will mich
nicht testen lassen eben von will ich
sowieso nicht aber ich würde nicht mehr
gerne dabei ich fühle mich danach heute
will ich dabei sein wenn er werden aber
infiziert ist dann kann der wird sich
leute also anstrengungen die sind dann
die leidtragenden sind nicht die anderen
leute die da drin sind wenn ich dem
einen ungeimpften ein laster sind
natürlich noch mehr umgehend zu handeln
was ist ja klar also die situation wäre
dann die also die ungeimpften neben für
sich in anspruch
die freiheit muss ich habe nicht daran
so leicht und dann stecken die
ungeimpften sich gegenseitig an dann ist
das argument das trägt zum beispiel auch
herr gassen vor oder sagt okay wenn die
ungeimpften sich gegenseitig infizieren
das ist nicht unser problem das ist wohl
unser problem zum einen ist es unser
problem für die pflegekräfte die sie
gerade noch vorgetragen haben und zum
zweiten ich kann ehrlich gesagt auch
leute nicht ins offene messer laufen
lassen weil sie fehler machen wo ich
genau was sie kapieren nicht was sache
ist denn es werden ja auch eben also
netz auf geherzt eben stoffe wir haben
das eigentliche problem nicht die
krankheit oder es wird gesagt also das
ist nur gefährlich für diejenigen die
über die kinder sich nicht impfen kann
angesagt ich muss laut durch diesen
fehler machen ins offene messer laufen
lassen das ist eine interessante
formulierung die habe ich von ihnen auch
schon gehört herr lauterbach und dann
haben wir auf der anderen seite ja wir
erinnern helge braun aus dem märz des
jahres 20 21 wo er sagte dass wir noch
mal dann ist einfacher molina selber
machen wir wenn wir jedem in deutschland
ein impfangebot gemacht haben können wir
zur normalität in allen bereichen
zurückkehren danach können wir keine
grundrechts einschränkungen eines
anderen mehr rechtfertigen und alle
einschränkungen fallen
sekunde das war das war auf jeden fall
falsch das war anfangs so kann man es
nicht sehen warum kommen wir also helge
braun ständig bei vielen punkten zu ja
auch sehr gut zusammengearbeitet immer
aber das war habe ich sofort als feind
betrachtet weil ich weiß als
epidemiologe als arzt dass viele leute
das impfangebot bekommen ist aber nicht
nehmen weil sie zum beispiel die gefahr
unterschätzen ich bin auch ebenfalls ich
habe viele leute geimpft hier sind
gekommen die waren eigentlich gar nicht
interessiert sich impfen zu lassen sie
sind ehrlich gesagt zu ihm gekommen weil
ich
noch nie waren die leute waren zum teil
so kann man kaum in den bus hoch und
kaum die zwei stufen und das sind
einfach menschen den kann ich nicht also
einen vorwurf machen kann das nicht
einschätzen wie konnte ich die die kamen
keine idee davon wie schwer ko wird
wirklich läuft wir haben auch keine idee
davon dass zum beispiel jemand der 35
ist also und hat einen risikofaktor zum
beispiel einen ideal mangel oder so
etwas das ist total hart rein gar nix
dazu vielleicht
ich finde das eine richtige position
dass man in der übergangsphase
tatsächlich versucht mittel wege zu
finden wie man zur normalität zurück
kommt und vielleicht ist zweig und drei
gehen die möglichkeit das zu erreichen
weil wir uns von der phase der pandemie
jetzt in der übergangsphase zur
normalität bewegen und da müssen wir
irgendwie natürlich diejenigen belohnen
die wir gehen aber es hat doch
normalität zurück aber was ich nicht
sehe der nächste schritt wie kommen wir
jetzt in die wirkliche normalität zurück
was ist denn der grenzpunkt wo wir dann
sagen passt mal auf wir haben jetzt
wirklich ein angebot gemacht die
menschen die von denen sie sprechen da
sind genau diejenigen vor denen ich
sagen die haben noch gar kein angebot
bekommen die haben es noch gar nicht
gehört weil die sprache nicht stimmt bei
der kulturkreisen anderer ist weil sie
vielleicht auch andere informationen
haben wir müssen die erreichen aber
jetzt gibt es natürlich auch nur frage
wie wir sagen solidarisch wir müssen uns
so lange bemühen wie es geht aber
irgendwann ist es wie bei den bezahlten
tests wir müssen doch dann irgendwann
sagen jetzt müssen wir zur normalität
zurück und den punkt sehe ich bei ihm
nicht dass sie irgendwann mal sagen
jetzt ist wirklich der punkt erreicht wo
wir
verhältnismäßig agieren ist die
verhältnismäßigkeit ist ja in vielen
dingen schon verloren gegangen schon
zigmal ich habe das schon öfter mal
gesagt wir sehen frauen ich habe frauen
fahren auf einem fahrrad dahinter die
dass die tochter ohne helm aber mit
maske ja dieses
angstgefühl in der gesellschaft ist ja
da aber irgendwann muss man auch zur
normalität zurück und schauen sie mal
bei anderen atemwegserkrankung ist es ja
so da wissen wir
die kinder werden sich bis zum alter von
zwölf jahren alle natürlich immunisieren
es gibt keinen impfstoff der in
deutschland regelmäßig empfohlen wird
für kinder außer für die influenza nicht
für die erweiterung gibt es leider noch
gern im schaft und bei den anderen fast
200 atemwegserkrankung auch nicht so
haben wir uns leider daran gewöhnen
müssen dass die kinder sich natürlich
immunisieren und jetzt immer noch die
geschichte aufrechtzuerhalten wir müssen
die kinder unter zwölf impfen damit die
pandemie zu ende geht weil die
erkrankung schlimm ist und weil ballon
cupid haben geht meines erachtens an der
fütterung von einem archiv heran das
eigentlich nicht mehr so zu halten ist
da gibt es genügend studien die das
eigentlich widerlegen und jetzt möchte
wirklich immer wieder bei den kindern
anzufangen
halte ich für leben herrschte haben sie
einen freedom day gefordert und jetzt
ist einmal ganz kurz nur lauterbach mit
dem protest der prozess ist ganz simpel
also dass in dem punkt war er schon
häufiger anderer meinung
international wird hat longo wird bei
kindern beschrieben kurve dies eben
nicht nur eine atemwegserkrankung
sondern es ist eine erkrankung des
endothels also der kleinen blutgefäße
die kleinen blutgefäße in den organen
gehirn niere lunge werden also mit den
werden in mitleidenschaft
und da ich halte aber die zahlen bringt
das system ist es nicht also zum ich
habe heute zum beispiel kamen wieder
interessanter neuer daten aus israel hat
eine im gegensatz zu uns eine sehr gute
datenlage und da kam raus wieder ein
prozent der kinder die erkannt worden
das war ein telefonservice da waren also
sehr viele also kinder befragt wurden
über 16.000 1 prozent also der kinder
waren ins krankenhaus gekommen für
profis und also es hatten nach einem
halben jahr je nach alter liegen die
kinder älter sind ist es mehr zwischen
zwei und elf prozent der kinder hatten
noch beschwert nicht allzu gravierend
habe ich einen spieler zum teil
schlechter konzentrieren das war wohl da
kann man sich fragen wie kann denn das
sein denn so eine normale
atemwegserkrankung geht ja auch sofort
weg na ja das ist es eben kurve ist
keine normale art und weise cargo es ist
eine gefäßerkrankung die gefäße werden
mit in mitleidenschaft gezogen das
endothel reagiert ac 2 rezeptor ist auf
jeder will ein endlager drauf und das
ist was die linken
den an der unterricht wieder sorgt
islamisten behinderte zeit unterscheidet
sich einfach von anderen erkrankungen
hause haben mir ganz wichtig und ich ja
das recht und ich will einfach dass mit
der punkt so wichtig im international
werden die kinder mit ihren kurven
erkrankungen sehr ernst genommen in
deutschland müssen die kinder oma immer
um die anerkennung ihrer corvette die
kinder haben kam intensivieren die
argumente der anderen seite die kinder
haben am meisten gelitten sie sind
zahlenmäßig sie sollen ja auch in die
schule rein kann sich jetzt nicht zum
schluss durch solchen worauf liefert
denn das hinaus die vorschläge freedom
die für kinder ich würde dann
tatsächlich ein riesiges experiment ab
ich kenne keinen wissenschaftler die
sich damit ernsthaft beschäftigt der
garantieren würde der garantieren würde
dass die kinder die kurve gehabt haben
symptomatisches kurven nicht nur
effizient sondern symptomatisch dass die
nicht in fünf jahren auch noch
beschwerden
wahrscheinlich
geologische plausibilität hier auch ja
das
kann niemand sagen wenn wir rausgehen
das nicht ein ziegelstein auf den kopf
nein aber
noch sagen ja die große studie die die
nie zitieren den iren oder ich nicht
gehört aber zumindestens aus england pro
4 wochen 50.000 die einzige fall
kontrollstudie wo man 50.000 personen
involviert hat die die andere höchsten
stufe der evidenz steht war man halt
eine gemischte studie hatte und nicht
kein telefon interview geführt hat eine
gute studie aus deutschland 1700 kinder
und die studie aus der schweiz die haben
eindeutig belegt dass longo wird in der
größenordnung nicht bei 1 von zehn
kindern oder von zehn personen aus
sondern 2,5 prozent und dass die
hauptsächliche altersgruppe die
betroffenen ist frauen sind zwischen 50
und 69 zu dem zeitpunkt als die deutsche
forschungsministerin 7 millionen euro
gegeben hat um longo wird in deutschland
auch zu befassen also ist bestimmt nicht
dass es nicht geforscht wird an dem tag
hat sie noch gesagt 1 zu 10 also es ist
nicht gewisse darm und narrativ was man
dafür doch das ist eigentlich den
totalen und den daten auch nicht
entsprechend an das narrativ es genau
umgekehrt die us-studie in england die
studie in israel ich eben erwähnt habe
die großen studien aus der universität
gefahren und er geht ist eine basis und
es ist jetzt keine gefahr wo man sagen
kann die kinder sterben das ist nicht so
im großen und ganzen ist es so die
kinder also müssen ungefähr ein prozent
muss ins krankenhaus stellen sie sich
vor dass hätten ich habe dort noch mal
gebet dass wir bei ihr
würden bus die busfahrten während so
dass also ständig unfälle passieren
würde ein prozent der kinder ins
krankenhaus das geld an die hölle los
und es hat was sie sagen das was jetzt
in thüringen passiert was in anderen
bundesländern passiert dass man den
kindern schwarze masken zu bekommen dass
man sagt sie sollen in die schule sie
sollen endlich wieder in die schule das
ist hochgefährlich nannte die schule
sollen die kontrollierten die zahlen die
schule gekonnt wenn wir also sozusagen
mehr retten
es gibt gute test also möglichkeiten was
man den unterrichtsausfall punkt bleibt
wenn ein kind wenn die kinder dreimal
pro woche getestet werden und ein kind
hast dann positiv ist bleibt zu hause
und dann waren die an werden sie
in den schulen weit ginge und da sollen
wir in den schulen so lange weiter
machen bis wir hundertprozentig auch
trennen können was longo fit ist und wo
kinder vielleicht unter psychischen
schäden leiden weil sie so lange in der
isolation und hinter einer maske waren
aber also wo präzise zu ermitteln ist
woran die kinder eigentlich ein wenn wir
werden wir haben alle ewigkeit alle
kinder impfen müssen wenn sie das jetzt
wollen dass in diesem jahr alle kinder
geimpft werden dann wird auch im
nächsten jahr 110 millionen kinder
werden jedes jahr geboren die wären ja
nächstes jahr sind die weder naiv dann
müssten ja alle geimpft wenn die
tatsächlich jetzt die impfung fordern
nein also wenn die was das problem sich
lösen würde werden es also gut ginge
wenn wir in deutschland also diese quote
bei den erwachsenen hinbekämen das also
wir tatsächlich selbst dann werden wir
öffnen wir sinkende fallzahlen haben das
ist ja der punkt also dann wird es
ungefähr sagt ungefähr 56 7 prozent also
brauchen wir noch an doppelte geben
würde dann könnte man öffnen dann wurden
aber nach dem geöffnet wurde nur um die
fahrt zahlen trotzdem segnen abonnenten
bitte und die kinder was würde dann
passieren wenn die fallzahlen nach
einiger zeit gesunken sind dann sind
natürlich auch nicht nur die kinder
gefährdet und wenn ich das so machen wie
in der schule wie gerade bescheiden dass
ich dort testen und die kinder also
sozusagen nach hause schicke die positiv
sind dann haben wir das problem gelöst
aber wie das problem gelöst das virus
wird noch weiter zu polieren solange wir
denken können wird das weiter zirkuliert
das ist nicht alle infizieren
nicht alle kinder infizieren dass das
system was sie vorschlagen jedoch dann
nicht ja und nein es geht schon auf also
wenn wir tatsächlich fahrt zahlen haben
die stetig sinken bei gewähren die
kinder gar nicht infiziert irgendwann
mal dann irgendwann wären tatsächlich
gebe es noch weniger ausbrüche ja es
wäre doch dann so wenn die werden die
fahrzeuge jetzt sagen wenn der herr
sagen weil das frühjahr kommt wenn wir
liegt also werden wir jetzt über den
winter kommen wir haben sinkende
fallzahlen dann kommt das frühjahr dann
sind da die fahrzeuge noch dann haben
wir solche fahrer zahlen wie wir sie im
format das incident von fünf oder sechs
dann infiziert sich auch kaum ein kind
dessen mutter dann also ich stelle ich
stelle fest der nächste winter kommt ich
stelle fest dass jetzt tatsächlich
gesundheitsämter in einzelnen
bundesländern entscheiden die schulen
verfahren vorteile sie wissen die legen
jetzt fest welche lehrer in quarantäne
gehen welche erzieher in quarantäne
gehen welche kinder in quarantäne gehen
und machen das unterschiedlich ist das
kann auch nicht besonders gesund sein
was wir da die hat ja schon immer das
läuft ja schon immer nicht so richtig
gesund
und bei den kindern merkt man auch ist
es besonders kompliziert weil wir müssen
für sie entscheidungen fällen jeder
erwachsene soll diese entscheidung nach
wie vor für sich fällen oder würden sie
auch sagen herr lauterbach es kann der
punkt kommen wo wir leben vielleicht
sogar erwägen müssten für nein ich will
eigentlich nicht erwirken das ist also
wie gesagt ideologisch nicht zu
rechtfertigen und sie ist auch nicht
also politisch durchzusetzen von daher
würde ich das nicht versuchen und wir
sind jan josef liefers bei der frage
wie wir eigentlich in den nächsten
winter marschieren was würden sie sich
wünschen für den herbst und den winter
dieses besonderen jahres es ist dann
schon das zweite kroner ja
ich denke dass viele fragen die im
moment so im raum schwirren und die man
an die medizin oder an die politik
stellt vor allem wenn man sie an die
medizin stellt dort gar nicht
ausschließlich nur hingehören es gibt
immer mehr fragestellungen die keine
reine medizinische antwort mehr wo das
nicht erreicht wo man einfach in die
gesellschaft zu tragen muss und sich die
frage stellen muss wie wollen wir
eigentlich generell leben welche art von
risiken also wenn wir jetzt sagen also
jeder kranke ist einer zu viel
also dann
es wird viele krankheiten geben wir
bleiben nicht gelebt wir müssen das auch
nicht wir sollen ist auch nicht wir
sollen infekte haben jeder kinder hat
sagt ich habe selber kinder also 14
infekte im jahr super fürs immunsystem
oder schlecht für die eltern die
schlafen ein wenig aber all das ist also
wie wollen wir eigentlich miteinander
leben und welche art von
risikomanagement wollen wir in zukunft
haben 100 prozent safety zero gar nichts
mehr oder oder was erlauben wir und
natürlich werden auch an anderen
krankheiten immer leute sterben und auch
da ist jeder einer zu viel wenn man sich
natürlich auch so einen standpunkt dann
stellt man wird es verrückt also das ist
eine frage glaube ich die geht auch ein
bisschen in die gesellschaft zurück dass
das eine und das zweite ist dass ich mir
sehr wünschen dass der diskurs den wir
also wir unterhalten uns ja hier jetzt
total friedlich aber in der twitter welt
der social media welt auch zum teil auch
in der presse geht es ganz anders zu und
ich wünsche mir dass wir am ende dieses
jahres mit der aussicht auf den freedom
day waren und jetzt kommt von unseren
bäumen unterkommen und abrüsten was was
adjektive was sprache angeht was dass
wir wieder zurückfinden zu einer form
miteinander verschiedene konträre und
zum teil auch abstruse meinungen zu
verhandeln und aber es ist auszuhalten
dass man können wir nämlich das konnten
wir schon mal das können wir gerade
nicht und diesen und diesen diese
stigmatisierung also von gruppen die aus
irgendwelchen gründen weiß der kuckuck
was sie werden schon gründe haben eben
diese impfung nicht vor allem dass damit
muss man sehr vorsichtig umgehen weil
auch das kann ganz schön viel porzellan
zerschlagen